[Musique]
amoureux passionnés ils abordent malgré
les écueils et les courants violents
l'objet de leur rêve c'est vaisseau de
pierre
la conchée petit b à rebours trois des
six ido fortifiée par vauban pour
défendre le port de saint-malo face aux
vaisseaux ennemis ces fortins ont
aujourd'hui leur ange gardien ils y vont
par aman pas pour la guerre
[Musique]
est ce que vous venez de la première
fois
vous l'avez vous la première
oui je devais avoir dix huit ou vingt
ans c'était la première fois je découvre
l effort et j'avais démissionné pour le
garder pendant l'été et après tous les
ans survenu et pendant plus de 30 ans 35
ans d'assister à la dégringolade à son
sa déchéance complète quoi
alors alain etienne marcel a entrepris
de sauver le petit b
il restaure cette ultime rempart avant
le port de saint-malo seul et à ses
frais
l'oeuvre de vauban enfin trouvé son
sisyphe elle ne facilite pas pour autant
son débarquement
là il fait beau et facile mais j'ai
quand même pris de bain en plein hiver
alors vous êtes le seigneur ou le
serviteur de l'endroit les titres à
pense rires c'est du style propriétaire
j'en veux
oui au service de l'endroit où j'en suis
ravi je me décoiffe impose accueillir et
bienvenue au petit b
mon
bon
abandonné pendant plus de 100 ans
laissée à la merci des squatteurs et des
tempêtes le fort vie grâce à ce drôle de
seigneurs
tour à tour capitaine manoeuvre maçon il
fait ça choque ou leçon plomb a repris
des outils et les plans du 17e pour
respecter l'esprit de vauban
je m'étais fixé une vingtaine d'années
vingtaine d'années physiquement parce
que c'est très dur je sais qu'à 80 ans
je n'aurais pu le tonus peut-être enfin
je ne sais pas
puis financièrement parce que c'est
énorme également donc une vingtaine
d'années et je tiens à le terminer
comme je voudrais devoir terminer voyez
le remède dans l'état qu'il n'aurait
jamais dû quitter keitel et à 2710 voilà
et leur présenter ainsi rien ne sera
plus beau que de présenter dans l'état
dans lequel il était
les copains viennent en renfort pour le
browser
boynton
chaque année ils débarquaient 20 tonnes
de matériaux pour restaurer cette
forteresse bon c'est toujours un peu
chaud mais
notre homme bien
serviteur fidèle acharnée alain etienne
marcel s'est mobilisé les énergies
fossiles devait
y avait le courage je préparais déjà
mais ça n'était actrice
cet ancien huissier de justice est
devenu représentant en pharmacie pour
financer sa passion puis son propre
patron pour passer un maximum de temps
sur son fort avec rigueur depuis 14 ans
il a refait toi charpente vous de
citernes des pensées des hectolitres de
sueur et toutes ses économies pour
remettre le petit b sur pied
[Musique]
je ne pas compter je sais que je suis
régulièrement
qu'une paille un peu sous l'eau pour
respirer mais je vais très bien donc
non c'est pas important
plus de deux millions d'euros le
monument est sauvé mais beaucoup reste à
faire
à un kilomètre et demi au nord-ouest du
petit b un autre vaisseau de guerre
voici le chef-d'oeuvre de vauban 65 m de
long 35 de large 25 de hauteur en pleine
mer le fort le plus difficile à
construire est aussi le plus dur à
accoster
à son approche une partie des 21
propriétaire est sous tension
parce qu'après trop près et
fois produire un bon ben on s'énerve et
contre-ordres pagaille si on l'a on est
trop du même bord
l'accostage et nerfs
des travaux d'hercule pour restaurer ce
mastodonte de granit bombardé par erreur
à la libération en 2015 la brèche
aujourd'hui restauré et est encore
énorme et l'entrée dévastée
c'est ici que nous avions rencontré
alain rondeau aujourd'hui disparu le
président fondateur des amis de la
conchée connaissait comme sa poche ce
dédale de souterrains où repose depuis
trois siècles les lourds canons de
défense du fort c'est quand même gros ça
fait 1600 m² prix d'achat 150000 euros
c'était il ya 25 ans ça paraissait fou
comme ça mais en fait on s'était dit au
fort de louis xiv à vendresse en halo
sera pas tous les jours alors on peut
toujours
acheter que l'on verra après et puis on
se dit que finalement on pourrait tenter
de les restaurer un petit peu on a
commencé puis on s'est pris au jeu qu'on
a mis vingt ans il ya bien encore un vin
au moins 20 ans a essayé de tout
terminer c'est pas beau ça
les premières pierres qui remonte
à près de 60 ans
les compagnons profitent des grandes
marées du fort dégagé à ses pieds pour
remettre ces pierres à leur place
d'origine là haut sur les remparts
mieux vaut s'éloigner
pas des pros du bâtiment ils sont
industriels médecins ou commerçants
alors le plus souvent ce sont des
entreprises qui réalisent les gros
travaux financés grâce aux subventions
publiques alain ici c'était comment il
ya 25 ans ben c'était un champ de ruines
il y avait le plus la partie la plus
haute cd l'angle l'a1 de cette maison
tout raser à cause des bombardements qui
avait tout détruit et on s'est attaqué à
ça
on a ramassé les pierres et on a
commencé à construire le premier logis
[Musique]
résultat spectaculaire
vauban reconnaîtrez ces bâtiments des
officiers reconstruit à l'identique
reste qu'on peut aborder ces machines de
guerre en douceur avec plus de poésie
[Musique]
au loin à rebours l'île mystérieuse le
plus secret des forts de la baie
killed in prend le large peu importe la
météo elle y va tous les jours d'été on
la surnomme la sirène d'arbaud
pourquoi un enfant âgé presque mais nous
avec moi donc
ouais c'est à rebours
us open s'offre pas les a brûlés dans le
vocable de mai
du caractère c'est
c'est vraiment ça en même temps comme
hier elle est magique
pour moi c'est déjà tourné mes enfants
puis mettez est vraiment les meilleurs
moments de ma vie dont
[Musique]
en vacances cette professeur
d'histoire-géo on ne rêve pas de longs
voyages
elle préfère ce caillou hérissé
d'écueils sont ils à elle ou presque
[Musique]
qu'ils dînaient ce que tu sais à qui
appartient ce ford oui alors il
appartient donc c'est une personne
privée je visite pas c'est
quelqu'un qui qui est qui et passionné
qui qui veut rester caché mais qui a qui
a rénové le fort
extrêmement bien tout seul véhicule ah
non il n'est pas là donc pour l'instant
je suis on est tout seul sur l'île
[Musique]
qu'il dîne reste donc sur les grèves et
les rochers pour goûter cette île
déserte en plein mois d'août
[Musique]
petit jardin d'éden c'est sacré c'est un
peu caché tout on ne connaît pas
vraiment le bonheur en fait
difficile d'imaginer que jusqu'en 1870
sans canonnier matelots et capitaine
était retranché ici la sirène elle
éprouve un sentiment de liberté une île
pour souvenirs d'enfance intacte
immuable
[Musique]
puis en janvier j'ai fait mes premiers
pas à rebours l'été suivant donc c'est
quand même quand même un joli endroit
pour commencer à marcher et à s'amuser
quoi tu te sens pas trop seul ici n'ont
cessé cette mince et remplissent il ya
plein de vue il ya plein de choses à
faire
avec mon chien je me balade c'est
vraiment je me sens comme chez moi donc
je me sens pas celle du tout
vivre ses rêves d'enfant c'est aussi ce
qui donne des ailes à alain etienne
marcel heureux le seigneur du petit b
lorsqu'il survole la baie de saint malo
[Musique]
ah ben voilà mon domaine
il est placé au milieu de la baie de
saint malo l'epide pas beau
il voit sur toutes les places
vu d'en haut
on découvre également la stratégie de
bord
une stratégie qui aurait été efficace
pendant 180 ans aux dires des anglais
sur quand même des bons marins de bon
soldat on peut les croire d'ailleurs ils
s'y sont pas frottés après à saint malo
la ville est restée absolument
imprenable
[Musique]
pourtant les adversaires sont
redoutables
[Musique]
ses 189 d'énormes vaisseaux anglais
hollandais font de saint malo leurs
cibles privilégiées
pour se défendre des attaques venues de
la mer vauban érige si bastion sur les
îlots de la baie
protégée par les croisements des tirs de
leurs canaux le premier port de france
est inaccessible
doté de 18 bouches à feu d'une centaine
de soldats le petit b résiste aux
boulets des anglais
[Musique]
premier poste avancé il a couché
interdit toute approche aux escadre
ennemis jeu fort avait six canons de 48
c'est à dire il voyait des boulets de 48
livre de 27 kg c'est lé plus gros de
l'époque il n'y avait pas plus gros même
si on les bat on ne pouvait pas aller
mettre parce que le bateau s'enfonçait
sous le poids alors on peut et se diront
comment si canon contre une flotte qui
avait pas loin de 1 millier de petits
canaux 1 c'est parce que était sur le
sol donc bien précis on tient une une
salle à un boulet on voyait dans l'eau
il tombait il suffisait de corriger
hélas la fois d'après c'était bon
trois cents ans plus tard une légère
odeur de poudre flotte encore sur
l'effort ouais on se tire pas dessus
rien on ne combat pas mais chacun fait
son poursuit son son programme
la canche et je les connais pas tous ils
sont une vingtaine j'ai de bonnes
relations mais on sent quand même con et
chacun chez soi quoi
voit les travaux qu'on fait c'est pas
tout à fait les mêmes nous on est quand
même un gros seychelles une échelle plus
plus importante que les autres les eau
tirée par
consolide tandis que nous on est obligé
de reconstruire on cela m'arrive de leur
lancer quelques piques quand je vois
comment s'est restauré
gentilhomme voilà nous sommes des
gentilhommes outre une sonde et pas des
caractériels mais sont des gens de
caractère
misanthrope ce gentilhomme non bien au
contraire
les messieurs il ya des personnes qui
veulent aller visiter le fort je peut
vous emmener maintenant
partageur l'ancien navigateur solitaire
est aussi guide compteur embarque les
volontaires pour 5 euros l'entrée à l'un
était marcel c'est découvrir le petit b
jusque dans les entrailles de sa
poudrière
il ya des enfants je vais m'adresser
plutôt à eux parce qu'ils sont souvent
déçus il ya pas de cash au dépôt de
prison ont annoncé pour le 8 mai même
est retrouvé dans les archives du petit
b un rapport qui se passe en 1695
où il est écrit au sortir du cachot il
était calme et
alors je vous laisse imaginer
c'était parmi les soldats qu'ils étaient
ici où il y avait de temps en temps
insubordination ivresse enfin voyez ce
que je veux dire des sanctions
disciplinaires donc c'est là qu'on aime
était il était calme et
imaginé comme un navire la construction
de ce fort prendra à vauban ces temps on
continue nous avions ici 19 cas non plus
de mortier au milieu
pour manoeuvrer cette artillerie à peu
près 120 hommes plus une trentaine pour
l'intendance ici il peut y avoir 150 160
hommes ambiance d'un vaisseau de guerre
d'ailleurs vauban avait dit tout à fait
exact pour diriger un fort je ne veux
khan officier de marine fusse-t-il
cul-de-jatte ou man show
à faisait plus admirées l'échauguette
également la coupole de l'échauguette
une passe nord l'entrée se imprenable
ces forteresses ont pourtant soumise à
la loi de la mer
[Musique]
l'île déserte de la sirène n'est plus la
même à marée basse à rebours découvre
ses dessous deux kilomètres et demi de
paradis
[Musique]
à bourg qui est qui peut paraître
extrêmement hostile cancon à marée haute
nous offre une magnifique plage de sable
fin doré et puis des couleurs qui font
vraiment lagon
killed in doit partager son immense
terrain de jeu accessible uniquement par
très grands coefficients les pêcheurs à
pied envahissent son île pour quelques
heures seulement
guy saint jacques on en trouve à grandes
marées sur le banc
pour moi le paradigme c'est extrêmement
subjectif évidemment le paradis c'est un
endroit où l'on sent mieux en fait donc
oui pour moi le paradis certainement
mais moi ça
moi
ce soir champagne et galettes saucisses
au petit b alain etienne marcel reçoit
150 amis pour célébrer la fin d'une
quatorzième année de durs travaux
certains fournit du bois pour les
planches et d'autre des conseils des
bras tous ont participé
c'est un fond mais affolter mais je
crois comme tous les passionnés si on
arrive à créer des oeuvres comme ça il
faut être quelque part faudrait
tout son argent prochainement pour qui a
pâti mention douala donc c'est les
copains
pour nous remercier on va boire un coup
à notre bateau il ya des bateaux sa
tête défense de
la baie de saint malo
[Musique]
à bord de la conchée les compagnons se
sont fixés une vingtaine d'années pour
que le fort retrouve sa majesté la
moyenne belge sera alors de 95 ans en
attendant un nouveau trinquer à sa santé
c'est le but de la manoeuvre
des amis et copains tout ça c'est très
bien d'ailleurs on fait le fort que pour
toi on venir boire un couteau
[Musique]
non
les colosses de pierres entre les jours
et les nuits des amoureux d'efforts
[Musique]
une passion dévorante un peu hors normes
c'est ouf
[Musique]